all right Jason is with us in Wichita
Kansas hi Jason how are you good thanks
for calling me sure call how can I help
all I've been talking about getting out
that and we have expected together but I
don't think you're speaking directly
into your phone I'm having trouble
hearing you
oh sorry my wife and I have been talking
about getting out of debt and we have
yet to make a written budget she's one
of the control budget she always wants
to make it because she wants taking
trips and kicks asking me that we can
buy things that we don't have the funds
for obviously since we're in debt right
now and I wonder if her advice on how I
might go about talking about how we
actually do need to make this budget
okay well I think one thing is the
budget is a tool to get you where you
want to go and I think the first thing
you guys need to do sit down and talk
about where it is you want to go where
do we want to be and because it's
difficult to start talking about paying
a price to win until we define winning
and so where do we want to be I'd like
to have a million dollars I'd like to be
able to have enough money that we could
travel and do anything we wanted to do
or we had an emergency we didn't have it
wasn't stressful and I'd like to feel
like we were getting more traction with
our money given that that we worked this
hard I'd like to have more to show for
it I mean what is winning look like and
yalta need to kind of talk about dreams
again and why we're doing what we're
talking about doing if we get a Y or two
that we can agree on then it's then
you're paying a price to get to that
goal but if you just start paying a
price and there's no reason to pay a
price well then everybody gets her back
up and doesn't want to do the deal you
know so you got to have your Y out there
big enough before you start talking
about the what or the how and then you
say okay in order to get there what's
the fastest way to get there will we get
out of that and then that when we don't
have any payments we have control of our
most powerful wealth building tool which
is your income
and that'll take you to write straight
to where you want to go to so then when
you sit down to do the budget everybody
suddenly is willing to pay a price and
so that's when I use that phrase living
you know you want to live like no one
else so that later you can live and give
like no one else that you can pay a
price to hit this win you can pay a
price to get to where you want to get to
but if you just say hey I want to get us
on a plan so that you could spending
money that doesn't work nobody nobody is
all excited about that and again maybe
you take the book the Total Money
Makeover and you guys start reading
through it together and going okay this
is a plan we're going to go with or you
go to the financial peace class or you
go to one of the Smart Money events or
something like that and maybe you show
her some of the debt free screams on
YouTube some of the people doing their
debt free screams and go man what would
it be like to not have any debt and you
start you know listening to some of
those things they're very inspiring and
you know you just begin to get the
nobility of your why has to be bigger
than the grind of the day-to-day to get
there and if you have a big noble why
then you will do the you'll Buster but
you'll pay the price to get there you'll
you'll push and push and grind and
hustle and take the extra job and sell
stuff and not go on vacation and not buy
this luxury or that luxury that you
can't afford while you're just limping
along instead you get everything cleaned
up so that you have a better life in the
future and maybe maybe your big why is
you want to give more maybe we want to
be more generous but we're just not able
to right now and maybe we're sick and
tired of feeling stuck or feeling like a
rat in a wheel that's a pretty good
y-you know I don't want I don't feel
like a rat in a wheel anymore I don't
want to just run run run run run run to
get nowhere sick of this lack of
traction I'm sick of looking down and
going I'll work my butt off all year we
made 80,000 or we made 60,000 or made
40,000 and I got nothing to show for I'm
sick of it and that's what you're
talking about here we walk your way
through that that will get you there hey
guys Rachael Cruz here hope you enjoyed
that video from the Dave
see show if you want to watch another
great video check out my video three
things you should consider renting right
over here or click the link in the
description below